and we have a love letter to her take a
look
cynthia germinata does it all she is a
businesswoman a goodwill ambassador and
mother to natalie and stephanie better
known to the world by her stage name
lady gaga
cynthia knew that stephanie was unique
from a young age but says stephanie's
uniqueness and fierce independence made
her the target of some high school
bullies cynthia struggled with how to
best support her daughter and despite
decades of global success neither mother
nor daughter has ever forgotten how it
felt to be ostracized for just being
yourself
and so in 2012 they founded the born
this way foundation to support the
mental health of young people they've
taken direct steps to help children and
their parents access resources take
direct action and build community
they're on the right track baby and
we're so thankful to them for creating a
kinder braver
world for all of us
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
cynthia germanotta
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank
thank you for having me so grateful that
you have come here i'm so grateful that
you would have been i'm pinching myself
oh my goodness
you're so beautiful too by the way
beautiful
you're so beautiful
i am i'm just so honored that you would
come here today
what was the spark
um may i ask for starting the born this
way foundation was there a moment or an
instance i know there's history there
the things that inspired the foundation
there were a couple of things
the first was kindness or what i would
call the absence of kindness
she's written about something she calls
a negative space
and it's a moment when
somebody is unkind to you and there's a
negative space and you as a human being
have an opportunity to fill that space
with kindness
and because there were many moments
where that space wasn't filled for her
it affected her very very deeply and it
had a kindness had a really
transformative impact on her life and
because it was absent absent
she developed anxiety and depression at
a very very young age
the other inspiration were the
incredible stories that we heard from
young people all over the world as she
started to tour and travel and we made
it a point to sit down with them and
talk to them and understand how they
were feeling and what was happening in
their lives and the stories were so
similar to hers
and
that said these young people they wanted
to be part of a change and they were
like gaga how did you do it
how did you turn your life around you
know what were the things that you did
and um
those stories impacted both of us very
deeply and i remember one instance we
were in paris and she was touring and we
heard just incredible heartfelt stories
and we got on the plane to come home
and you know we
fasten your seatbelt you know we
strapped in and she looked at me and
said mom it's time
and i said time for what
and she said it's time to help these
help these kids now she's a kid at the
same time you know telling me that she
wants to help other young people
be kinder and braver to one another
and have resources you know be better
equipped to deal with their struggles
than she felt that she was and that was
the real genesis of the foundation
[Music]
you